[Music]
in makeup hack news school submitted by
Andy from Borneo low take a news yeah a
girl used her boyfriend's balls as a
makeup though I saw this I didn't see
this I saw this like a sponge like yeah
but she used to the actual balls I made
up running there yeah like yeah he's
just standing there like holding his
dick up so that like she can you are
really fast no ladies consider the balls
are so soft and they really absorb all
that makeup texture that you guys want
to get on your face and evenly
distributes that as well I thought hey
that's a good idea for view like if you
were just like what could get the most
views like balsa you know okay but what
if she breaks up with his he's pretty
young like she's 18
what is yeah like she's not gonna marry
this guy probably like one of them's not
down the line you're making it [ __ ]
sexual it's not know they're not so have
you guys both on your evenly applying
makeup that's true you're taking it
along Direction good fine and here's
what's more waterproof than a ballsack
yeah nothing the moisture that that that
the average human ball sack on if you
guys are aware of this encounters is is
higher than any other texture known
known to man so epiderm mine moisture my
and so and that's why the ball set
really is ladies at home for everybody
ever Calais that's instrument for for
mega vamp okay I agree I heard when you
want to get into the corners of your
eyes are supposed to pinch the skin of
the balls that means where the deck hat
goes that's an urban legend it's worth
it with a dick there's different tools
you don't use math girl for your
lipstick do you oh you cannot be absurd
no you don't by the way you're going to
teach me but you use the dick these
corners is perfect for the penis radical
is too big berry no yours like that so
big no here's the thing this makes me
honestly angry because big q-tip wants
all one's chicks to think like all you
clean your ears with the q-tip you can
never be able to keep well that's what
big to to
big q-tip told my sister growing up I'm
look big cute big q-tip the big
complaint big pharma yeah I got you
greatly hugest cute cute it's the only
one everyone buys from it's got the blue
packaging I need to call cons lobby all
right I'm in makeup has chicks thinking
like Oh use only little [ __ ] sponges
[ __ ] actually makes you break out yeah
but what is you got to get something
natural it was made for the face yeah
what do you think the cave woman did hey
I used to be able and I didn't freak out
understand everything my baby blunders
fine because why
well I haven't broken out I've been
using for like three years but have you
seen what is capable with balls and dick
you haven't seen your skin yet it's on
it's like it's like a new convenient
Marshall can you show us after like once
we can't can you like I'll give your
audition one of you guys apply it on
each other you know there's a Romana I
won't do it to him no you sound
experiment experience doesn't work on
the million you'll understand this [ __ ]
and humid Irma yes or penis and a
network on the pillow you know epidermis
and male epidermal are different we
suffer me we sweat way more and why do
you think the penis only has one hole
it's the function like a quilt
cool yeah you put a little bit of ink
and let me get the corners perfect
eyeliner all kinds of stuff mm-hmm
it's all part of the God's plan it's not
much when it's not wheezing it's our
plan because mean barks laughs Slattery
but it's not if God's plan we're still
attack Johanna is 18 year old from
Florida and her boyfriend Damon was 20
years old they went viral on Twitter
because Johanna
Coburn on Twitter and I'm just all text
you get up rolling but you see this
person sentences is so crazy when you're
from Georgia you get 30 repeats you go
viral awesome this is what you tweet it
out first
would you mind to yell dare me to post a
video of me using Damon s as a Beauty
Blender
oh my gosh you dare yourself no one
jumps off and there she goes I think I
started a new Instagram makeup trend
this is a video is it a trend now this
is oh my god oh it's perfect I don't
know why they're laughing is this holy
moment they're just doing historical
things you look like a beauty blender
blender really nice really easily yes
yeah got some smooth as balls though
this shape is not baggy and falls well
you know the room temperature is
probably pretty warm because you know
it's not natural the reason why we have
all hair is so we can help with the
blending look how nice you look in that
picture after that so you would never
think again falls on her forehead you
should see the before picture you don't
feel that you have em no I don't feel
soft watching that Jeremy yeah but the
blah blah Oh breakup for sure why
there's no Jana
well because her father's going to kill
uh IIIi think that's unfortunate and
just and in a couple he's gonna beauty
blend so many more girls yep no her
dad's gonna kill him that's one of the
close-minded parts of this whole thing
yeah what would you do another your
daughter oh I killed my kid yeah I would
absolutely cannot know if that was my
daughter yeah I would you like it
absolutely blown away your daughter mmm
would she have any repercussions Oh
she'd have said boyfriend I ground her
for like a week and be like yes think
about your dead boyfriend always about
how using salsa makeup tools for one
week okay glaze on your areas so your
daughter you'd be like honey that was so
bad I think that would be my daughter
your daughter a little balls on her head
yeah she says this all happened when one
day she was taking a shower and she got
out of the shower she started doing her
makeup and then that's when Mike her
boyfriend was just messing around and
put his balls on her face I'm like what
position were you been
probably sitting down like you know one
girl thank you to me I like on the
ground like a present posit Mira no she
was standing in the counter and he was
standing on the counter
that's very mutually beneficial
situation because I think the boyfriend
had a shiny ball problem - yeah now
through the foundation his balls are now
mat and so I never shine he could feel a
little more confident about his balls I
think there's nothing wrong with that
you laugh oh yeah you bet no I think
it's great I think it's amazing the dad
is balls no he's not - yeah Jesus such a
riot oh yeah guys feel uncomfortable -
balls there's a lot of guys who feel
uncomfortable out there ball - when do
you guys ever show your boss says I look
more than you thought of those answers I
like I don't know what to say
ha did you show your toaster public
pretty often especially in the summer
yeah but still it's not the same
obviously show your toes actually uh how
come girls bleach their butthole no we
don't because we happen all the
important people do that in pornos yeah
because we begged them to and then guys
to see the pornos yeah and they go you
know pink booty ho like that what why
don't you got a pink booty ho mm-hmm oh
that's bad I'm above that I'm
questioning on not a day it's fortunate
that the curve foundation on our face
matches ball color yeah oh yeah it'd be
I think it just kind of sucks because
you have no real range of motion that
gets so short sure her skin under the
match my ball color okay you're all but
your own ball color doesn't match your
own skin color bill turn elbows on the
ball texture and rougher but it gets the
job done are mine Ross are my black
mm-hmm my ball back so that would be
looks like they're for falling
they're like elbow pads yes on the nuts
yeah but they're even an income and then
they could it's like one of those things
where you can pull the head off and like
you know wash the dishes better didn't
they just figure out what's it I wonder
if you wash his balls it's probably got
a lot of ball sweat there they be just
smearing all over
we might just watch this ball I would
hope yeah that's why I was saggy after
the shower it tends to do that all right
it's all warm woodsy dip them in a cup
of warm water that's true exfoliate its
ball skin
yeah good it's kind of like when you go
to the what do you call it the nail
salon and they dip your feet in or the
massage not feel so good yeah
makes me want to pee for some reason and
it's like that pee thing we probably did
this balls in a cup of tea a tea bag
yeah no yeah okay yeah they you know how
like when you go to the massage or
whatever you put your feet in that
teasing that verbal nerves and all that
[ __ ] what does it do done I was like
[ __ ] dengue and there's never been
above 29 you got a pedicure or what no
they give you a foot massage it comes in
a bucket full of this Brown soup Teague
oh they line it with a trash bag yeah we
don't want our they're too lazy to wash
it maybe they're trying to clean your
feet was it a massage smells great
though it's like they call it some tea
thing I don't know I was just thinking
maybe that's what he does puts a little
Pharaoh food makes that and put his
balls inside or something yeah I must
say I don't you does that I'm gonna say
he just takes his ball down puts him on
a Facebook and make it fun that's my
guess but she's a wild child
that's a cool challenge wouldn't so you
can't even know the salty balls
challenge festival balls are down on the
ground again although review video too
short kid I think it'd be really cute
it's really if your dad would [ __ ]
get over it yeah but he probably
wouldn't so it could be like you know
boyfriend does my makeup boyfriend does
my makeup with his dick challenge yeah
with his balls big involved [ __ ] [ __ ]
and balls you do that it was just oh
yeah he has nothing to lose what I would
really truly love him this is me getting
personal is to use my butt on me to use
my butt your butt party apartment is
your bottle
my butt hurts ice is like way bigger
than my face well I think I would like
to get deeper than anything else make it
like that in your butthole no let me
cover my butt ever so gingerly in and
make up
things when you just look black yeah and
then she like bits her that's a lot of
nature and I was just really thinking
other $20 each so be really nice it's
really important I know but this is
Delphi where they put the cake interface
there you know red mmm
it might be easier to blow-dry someone's
hair with your farts Oh mmm I think your
parts with burn hair is off true oh no
yoga for no longer to eat a lot of
Mexican food yes we ate a carrot so this
girl she ended up tweeting out this I am
sad for the people who are genuinely
upset about this because you clearly
haven't reached this level of comes up
comfort in your life and that just sucks
because she's saying that she receives
our life relationship goals defers yeah
a lot of negative responses and just
people talking about I can't imagine
once you get older and you marry someone
else like this is like forever what you
gonna be known what kind of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] is that if my current wife had
a base like smothered in balls all over
the internet that doesn't matter that's
been she washed her face
why are you body shaming her why is that
okay why wait why are we body shaming
this guy why can we body shame dudes for
their balls on this girls I like it but
if a guy if you want your makeup put on
by a girl's boob I'd be like really
what's up okay
those chemicals Muslim and you know I
just think that girls always Barbie
shame guys about their dick stuff that's
true have you ever sent a girl addicted
how did she react yeah
oh she did because she we liked each
other cuz I get like hey [ __ ] off don't
ever send me a [ __ ] again text right now
exactly that's one of the responses and
then I'm like you know wow thanks a lot
first of all I trusted you a lot by
sending you this picture and now you're
being vulnerable right it's nice I mean
I'm putting myself on a limb and I'm
saying I'm being vulnerable please like
accept my big name like it and like
please appreciate my body and they're
like no [ __ ] you you saw I hate this
don't ever send me this [ __ ] I hate this
and just really makes guys go ahead
mom put them down yeah that is kind of
body sharing I didn't see it that way
that's because Society has a Minds like
really brainwashed and it's like they
don't really look out for us it's a man
it's the matriarchy but the matriarchy
is [ __ ] crazy dude you guys should
just get in a huddle hug and kiss yeah
that's what we do we have support groups
yes
hello a lot of people do you want to
contact me and everybody else you see go
ahead and check the description box
below and follow our social medias is
the Grahams and Twitter's for more
videos click up there baby
[Music]